c'est qu'on finit d'ici et d'ailleurs je
suis content de vous retrouver une fois
de plus aujourd'hui je vous emmène à la
rencontre de deux copines deux
baroudeuses partir de 2018 pour un road
trip dans le monde
elle s'appelle mais les l'insee elles
nous font découvrir leur histoire et
surtout de belles images
[Musique]
salut l'insee s'allume l ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai dans l'introduction vous
étiez des baroudeuses je vais pas mentir
[Musique]
vous êtes parti en repris pour 2018
c'est ça on va parler des pays que vous
avez visité et puis pourquoi vous avez
dû arrêter ce road trip prématurément
je crois que vous êtes parti d'abord
nouvelle zélande et suit alors la
nouvelle zélande vous nous fait
découvrir un petit peu ces grands je
crois sur le tube est effectivement
passé composé de deux îles passé
beaucoup plus de temps dans l'île du
nord est avec lyon dès que les beaux
paysages imaginés fait l'annoncé
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est très bon signe énormément de
pise et je peux passer très vite de jean
de sable à la plage à jour est arrivé
c'était beaucoup plus de travail
on est en chute de pour travailler et
socialement juste et encore vous avez
réussi à financer ce road trip c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous partiez vous
travaillez sur place des visas français
et la possibilité de rester besoin le
pays au travail
on nous a ramenés d'ailleurs plein de
photos 1 sur votre instagram
nouvelle zélande et tout ça ils sont
vraiment très très belle après la
nouvelle zélande il ya eu un autre grand
pays il a aussi l'australie c'est un peu
plus longtemps parce que là on est
vraiment resté un mois complet on a
beaucoup hésité
on a un voyage essentiellement en
camping-car puisque contrairement à la
nouvelle zélande en crète
on avait on n'avait pas de voiture et
voilà donc on apprécie t on a voulu
citer en camping car et on a aussi
travaillé 5 ou moins cinq morts
elle lui disait on il n'y avait
absolument rien rien autour d'elle nue
vous à paris xie tél wallace au coeur du
petit village est normalement ce n'était
pas censée s'arrêter là beauté santé
continuer nos milieux tout ça il ya eu
le commis 19 qui a débarqué et on avait
décidé si on allait retourner et la
catastrophe l'australie ferme ses portes
les avions étaient quoi on avait trouvé
une solution est ce qu'on cherche à leur
travail et c'est de plus en plus
difficile puisque les australiennes
terme des travailleurs la chaîne et on
retourne on a pu contacter l'ambassade
qui a affrété des avions
donc on est parti en fait parce qu'on
était dans une petite ville contre
travailler dans les crimes qu'on a vite
rejoint mêleront puisqu'on est pas
racine de melbourne dans les grandes
villes de l'australie où c'était
possible de protection et voilà donc ma
fille dans cinq heures de vol
donc c'était très
en france et est arrivée aux antilles là
il ya eu une quatorzaine en fait ce que
c'est obligatoire ont dorénavant comment
ça s'est passé cette 14e ça nous fait un
choc
après toutes ces heures d'avion tout ce
périple depuis l'australie d'arrivée et
est d'être un petit peu enfermé mais
c'était normal ce qui était plus
difficile n'est que la nuit tous les
jours heureusement on a eu cette 14ème
pour pierre se reposer se remettre dans
le rythme des antilles on a été contrôlé
et ça a l'air d'aller
vous pensez vous pensez déjà à allah
près après tout ça pas tout de suite
bien évidemment un
mais après est-ce que vous avez déjà des
idées de voyage vous continuez seront
repris alors oui c'est moi aussi elle de
sa voix y aller un peu plus proche
éventuellement pour les prochains
voyages
mais voilà donc là en ce moment en place
il ya les bleus et professionnellement
égal c'est un petit peu ça
voilà pour les moyens à sa peluche sur
toute la planète la caraïbe les
anciennes puissent y avons finalement
très loin souvent des monty picon a
quand même thème est il intéressant tout
révèle juste un coup juste regretter ce
sera notre futur projet alors je le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez un
instagram sur lequel on retrouve plein
de belles images vos voyages
je sais pas il est ouvert et public ou
pas est-ce qu'on peut communiquer
l'adresse aux téléspectateurs qui
voudraient aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil
g merci beaucoup merci l'insee et maël
de baroudeur je le disais tout à l'heure
avec de très très belles images que vous
inviter à les découvrir sur leur
instagram
il ya vraiment des choses très très
sympa à voir dans le monde et c'est
aussi ça le but de cette émission vous
faire voyager malgré cette période de
confinement merci de nous avoir suivis
c'est un plaisir de partager ce moment
avec vous c'est est confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs et on se retrouve très vite
sur la première
[Musique]